Marvel recently dropped a bombshell when it
announced that the Blade franchise is getting
a reboot, and that Oscar-winning actor Mahershala
Ali is taking the reins as the new Eric Brooks.
In the few days following that news, it seemed
everyone had something to say about the reboot.
There were plenty of tweets expressing excitement
over Ali's casting, and then there were those
that weren't so thrilled - including one promise
to "riot" if original Blade actor Wesley Snipes
wasn't involved with the new movie.
And now, Snipes has finally broken his silence
on the Blade reboot and Ali stepping into
his shoes.
It turns out, Snipes is totally cool with
the whole thing, and thinks you should be
too.
"No, no, no I ain't pissed off."
ComicBook.com obtained a statement from Snipes
in which he affirms that there are no hard
feelings toward Ali and he's not disappointed
over Marvel choosing to reboot Blade without
him - just complete understanding.
In his statement, Snipes even used two Arabic
phrases - "salaam," meaning "peace," and "inshallah,"
meaning "if God wills".
This is extra special, since Ali is Muslim
and Snipes practiced Islam from 1978 to 1988,
according to The Hollowverse.
Snipes said, in part,
"To all the DAYWALKERS losing their minds
right now, chillaaxx.
Although the news comes as a surprise, it's
ALL GOOD.
Such is the 'business' of 'entertainment!'
Much peace to the MCU crew – always a fan.
Honor and respect to the grandmaster Stan
[Lee].
Congratulations and Salaam to Mahershala Ali,
a beautiful and talented artist whose expressions
I look forward to experiencing for many years
to come.
Inshallah, we will someday work together.
Most importantly to my loyal fans, the incredible
outpouring of love is overwhelming.
I am grateful for the never-ending support."
It's always tricky business when a studio
decides to reimagine a property with a brand-new
face at the forefront - and when it comes
to Blade, a movie that changed the superhero
genre forever and has continued to influence
comic book adaptations to this day, there
was an even bigger risk for vicious attacks
from those opposed to the entire idea.
"Why can't you just be nice?"
'Cause the world isn't nice."
While the Blade reboot has already garnered
some backlash, it hasn't been as bad as it
could have been, considering the circumstances.
According to Vice, Snipes has long wanted
to play the vampire-hunting Daywalker again.
This is a classy response from Snipes.
There's certainly a chance that he feels a
bit upset about Ali taking over the franchise
and Marvel not yet extending an offer to appear
in the reboot in some capacity, but Snipes
seems genuine in his response.
He's right in saying that reboots are just
part of the entertainment business - especially
these days, when studios are constantly looking
to refresh properties for new generations
and draw in old fans with the irresistible
pull of nostalgia.
It was really only a matter of time before
Marvel looked to what's largely considered
the grandfather of superhero movies for a
refresh as the studio maps out its post-Infinity
Saga plans.
The Blade franchise rests in capable hands
with Ali, and Snipes can understand that.
His mention that he hopes to one day work
with Ali could spark talk of a potential Blade
reboot sequel in which Snipes does actually
have a role, but considering the first flick
is currently without a release date, writer,
or director, those conversations probably
wouldn't amount to anything substantial for
quite some time.
With Snipes having now broken his silence
about the Blade reboot, fans can now rest
easy knowing the only blood that will be spilt
is the blood that will go flying in the film
itself.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.